hu
les frais
les gars vous allez vous mettre pour la
première fois dans l'apd néo coach et
mes enfants pas les mêmes on se met
dedans comme on l'a vu il ya des
candidats
alors si ça vous plaît vous pouvez vous
retourner si ça vous plaît pas vous
restez d'oahu où vous voulez ça c'est la
version et n'aura non vraiment donc
comme dans the voice ils vont chanter
pour vous vraiment ils vont donner oui
mettent tout leur coeur nous voilà à
fonctionnement vous appuyez vous vous
tournez vous même ça se tombait ce sujet
c'est merveilleux alors le premier
candidat
abbas et on m'a mis jean michel moi je
pensais que c'était moi mais non alors
le premier candidat on va voir qui c'est
sale et les boules se mélangent dans
qu'est ce que je réponds que ce mélange
on y voit le premier qui chante c'est
parti il faut que tu te mettre là je
crois qu'il ya un petit problème voilà
vas-y
c'est une personne âgée la des palmarès
des zombies
débarqué moi car au bout des doigts j'ai
viré débat tu connais la fois qu'ils
brisaient ça je vous emmène au delà de
ce mur entre vous et moi des barques et
moi on va se toucher du bois en rythmant
les femmes au pour un coup de coeur
merci beaucoup je vais demander qui
s'est retournée sur toi et laisse le
public on pouvait plus en vue qu'est-ce
que tu encaisses que vous en avez pensé
la sensibilité c'était en même temps
pour un coach et du boulot pour le coup
ah bah oui il ya vraiment du boulot
c'est clair aller deuxième candidat
c'est parti est-ce qu'ils vont se
retourner ou pas les frérots de la vega
c'est parti elle est si fragile être une
femme libérée et tu sais c'est pas si
facile ne la laisse pas tomber
elle est si fragile être une femme
libérée
et tu sais c'est pas si facile une
analyse musicale pourquoi se retourner
sur cet artiste je vous présente
isabelle maury d'image adoré cette
fraîcheur cette fontaine le mot
fraîcheur c'est vraiment le monde
heureusement cette version usa est ce
que tu peux nous la faire à capella je
crois que la musique était trop fort ce
qu'on apporte tellement n'a pas bien
entendu le grain de t'avoir ma chérie
oui ça revient pourtant on a toute la
nuit 1 2,3 à ne la laisse pas tomber
mais c'est fragile être une femme
libérée tu sais c'est pas si facile ne
la laisse pas tomber
elle est si fragile être une femme
libérée tu sais c'est pas si facile
c'est une version
c'est une relation plus gourmandes moi
je trouve à l'est un autre candidat dans
the voice spécial frérot de la vega et
je peux vous dire que là c'est une
candidate messieurs c'est tout ce que je
peux vous dire et vous allez voir que la
vie est pleine de surprises
c'est vraiment c'est un cadeau pendant
deux ans
moi je veux mourir sur scène devant les
projecteurs
je veux mourir sur scène le choeur vaine
toute en couleurs où il s'en rendre paix
voulue oui je vous laisse une scène
g
les frères aux anges présente galy
douche
la soeur de dalida cacher un makoun
pjanic ou chez michou dimanche moitié
nue ou dans des bois quel qu'il soit
c'était une belle performance
j'ai tout donné oui j'ai on a évidemment
un dernier candidat
un membre de l'équipe à part entière ce
que vient spécialement pour vous les
frérots de la vega et ce n'est pas tout
la vache c'est parti mon kiki
mais
et
ça va c'est ça
m
hague
risen
m